[Music]
all right guys
our favorites another
yes oh
i like that intro let's do that every
time okay oh i didn't do it can you do
it again
not too late one more time one more time
he wants to be included ready
there we go i feel good you got to say
it out loud
true this is my airforce
the puckering butthole and then the poop
comes up i got a triple ass
oh i'm like what are these i don't like
anal sex
but it's kind of hot when the butt holds
how do you know you don't like it
tried it oh you tried
in the previous video you were saying
that you would never try it oh
but it's penetration yeah but i didn't
like it a tongue penetration or
fingerprints
tongues are nice
no okay you the the whole thing is doing
anal sex like i don't like to give
anal sex right but it's still hot when a
girl's booty hole does the blinky blink
oh you did the blinky music again you
know that's so cute
i just every time i i literally am
visualizing
an [ __ ] doing that mm-hmm
i don't want to anymore stop it okay
blink it blink
do it sometimes sometimes i do want to
watch joe and a porno just based off the
way he acts with when he's like
blinky
[Laughter]
oh he's like the nice piece but of the
porn industry he's like the tally of the
porn industry
hi want to get some blinky bling i
well i wish there was a yelp review for
[ __ ]
because you guys don't believe that i
can [ __ ] good so you wanna
how do you know they don't believe that
i don't know if you want yelp reviews on
people that have [ __ ] you
because what if it goes poorly because
you can't control what they're right
yeah you can
assuming they're gonna be honest great
experience but then the receiver alerts
and whoever you're trying to hook up
with can see how many people [ __ ] you
hey but you gotta understand there's
still those restaurants out there that
have like
two and a half stars but you're like i'm
still gonna [ __ ] and then if you use
the same line on somebody
they'll like if someone's like first he
said this to me and then i thought that
was pretty cute
private yelp like a suggestion box kind
of thing okay yeah maybe
a suggestion box that would be kind of
nice because then you could learn
success you could learn about yourself
suggestion box
sex gesture there we go okay back to the
suggest sex
i'm sorry keep going it's a suggestive
it's a [ __ ] babe suggestion survey but a
[ __ ] babe
no okay ready okay never mind you know
what we're talking about am i the
[ __ ]
blinking like blinky remember okay the
title is
the title is am i the [ __ ] for
causing my brother to become homeless
he almost killed my dog and i won't let
him live with me
okay here we go it says i am for
i am from lithuania and i had a really
really cute dog named azulus
who is a south russian of
charcoa i don't know how to say it sorry
probably one of the fluffy dogs
yeah it is not a common dog breed
outside of eastern europe
parentheses at least i don't think so so
you should google it they are so cute
i was in poland and i found one that was
homeless
i fed him when i was eating at a park
bench and he wouldn't stop following me
whenever
wherever i went and i felt bad for it
and i said [ __ ] it i'll take him home
with me
i kept him for a bit and i returned home
to lithuania and i brought him with me
i kept him at my house and i found out
after a couple of weeks this dog breed
is apparently banned in lithuania
and denmark wow absolutely [ __ ]
our work uh my country has been a bunch
of other
[ __ ] stupid wait what my country has
a bunch of other [ __ ] stupid laws
like banning alcohol sales after 3 pm on
sundays and 8 pm on other days
and a 20 year old oh sorry 20 year
drinking age
well my brother is pissed at me because
i refuse to drive him
to the city name a city uh
all the way across the country because i
was hung over and i wouldn't let him use
my car because i needed it for work he
then decided it was okay to try and
blackmail me and threaten me
and threaten to report my country's
animal control for having
uh the dog what a [ __ ] face yeah and i
told him to go ahead as i didn't think
my own brother would betray me
wow well this [ __ ] did also stating
i don't need a dog and that it is not
important and i shouldn't
break lithuanian law oh my what up
alcohol but he's trying to get alcohol
or what what was he
trying to get out of it to get a ride a
ride
is the brother like a meth head or
something that's some crazy ass behavior
yeah
he's gotta go get us fixed so he's gonna
like sell out this dog
yeah so then he continues animal control
came to my house
and asked to see my dog at two a.m
[ __ ] hell i gotta paint the dog real
quick i told what
you got to paint the dogs doesn't look
like it yeah it's a
chocolate lab it's not an oscar
that's a chihuahua and his ears back a
little bit
i told him to [ __ ] off and they refused
and it escalated and i won't say what
happened next because it violates rule
three
but they lost and left what's rule three
maybe there's a forum rule
of like committing crimes or whatever on
or whatever i don't know you can't admit
to it on reddit
the reddit
no no like for each form they have rules
like am i the [ __ ] you can't do that
whatever yeah
okay like the admin people of that
reddit forum maybe it's like sexual
harassment or something
like that it sounds like violent
confrontation yeah violent yeah
so then he says i know they're going to
put my dog down
to wait what i know they're going to put
my dog down too
i had a friend in poland drive over and
he took my dog and he has him for the
time being my dog is the kind of
sweetest dog i've ever seen
he wouldn't hurt a fly it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] for the lithuanian government
to consider it a fighting dog
or whatever i told my brother's
girlfriend about this whole
about this who loves animals and she
broke up with him and kicked him
out of the house whoa family can't take
him
and he's begging me to stay in uh
begging me for him to stay with him
i no i think he deserves being homeless
and a dog
i told him to [ __ ] off and i made sure
to let every single person he knows
what he did yep i told everyone of our
family members
and all of his facebook friends most of
whom hate him now
he keeps saying i'm such a horrible
brother and i'm betraying him for
telling everyone and not letting him
live with me i've got some [ __ ] from
other family members who are saying i
needed to forgive him
because he's family and it's just a dog
so i told them to [ __ ] off and eat [ __ ]
too
i lost my dog so [ __ ] him and [ __ ] my my
incompetent
government this is soviet [ __ ] that
we're still stuck with to make it clear
i'm asking if i'm the [ __ ] for
causing my brother to become homeless
and not letting him live with me that's
all i'm asking for
no his brother sounds like the kind of
guy that's like
oh this is the kind of thanks i get for
reporting
yeah he's not even doing the right thing
he's like i'm doing the right thing it's
an illegal dog and my brother's
committed a crime
oh god damn these dogs are gigantic i
want to see
ooh let's see i like big dogs
wait aren't those the guys that like
have like the
kind of little barrels of alcohol isn't
that the same that's the saint bernard
oh same foreign
[Applause]
like this can't be a real photo no way
further
pick the one pick the one in the right
yeah yeah well that one
no no no no that yeah that one oh that
jumper oh
whoa they look pretty crazy looking oh i
could see why they're illegal
wait what about that one on the top top
of that picture with the red guy
and a yeah yeah the jumping that's a
huge dog that's scary
that's a beast that shit's a lion man
and they said these are hunting dogs
fighting dogs fighting dogs well maybe
that's why it's illegal yeah i can see
why they're illegal i mean if one of
those things get angry
well there might be a dog in that one
movie with uh
the little like animated movie and we do
no no it was like a pet story or
something like that oh
yeah that one pets pets pets yeah yeah
that one right
yes where like louis ck's another thing
i think i would divorce my brother
yeah we're not brothers anymore no you
can't no divorce divorce
is that the word emancipate legal way of
doing it
i don't know because what you divorce
your parents right can you divorce your
brother
do you divorce you emancipate emancipate
don't they disown you
yeah parents disown you you emancipate
from them
all right and that is an ass that sounds
good yeah that guy
the guy the no the brother the guy no
he's kidding no of course the brother
the dog reporter the dog is a piece of
[ __ ] for causing all of this
you know there's a lot of people that's
a piece of [ __ ]
there's a lot of people that have that
sentiment of like it's just a dog or
it's just an
animal or it's it's not even like they
don't have that connection to animals
let them
let them fall in love with an animal and
then have the animal die
right [ __ ] that's really like
very very
um a common thing i think in my
like culture mexican culture like they
we view
dogs as like that's just a [ __ ]
animal like they stay outside they never
come indoors or whatever like that's
usually
the way we see animals a lot of asians
like that too true
filipinos yeah i met yeah brown he
changed my world because he's a human
that's just my [ __ ] son that got
murdered
i'm gonna go out there one day i'ma kill
all coyotes
oh that's not their fault it's just the
[ __ ] that i'ma exterminate their ass
there's no use for them why don't you
just find the one the one bad one
that the they're probably dead by now
there's probably evidence out there
yeah you got your justice jeff no it's
my game the human gang
versus the coyote gang they [ __ ] with
the wrong things that's hella
yeah but you call the human gang that's
like really weird you should be like the
sapien gang
the sapiens we are the sapiens the homo
in there
we are the homos it's like the ombres
the homos uh
but yeah i i feel like it's i didn't
realize until i was older that
like a lot of people feel that way if
you've never been close to an animal
then you probably feel that way i feel
like i've always been close to animals
so
i do too and they make me hungry but i
still don't feel like
it's just a fish yeah to me it's it
depends on the person's
relationship so like let's say let's say
i don't give a [ __ ] about fish right
but then i know that casey loves his
fish
so now then i channel i look the fish at
the fish through the way casey does
so i think for the brother that's weird
even if the brother was like i don't
give a [ __ ] about animals
but your brother cares about animals
he's like how is this brother gonna care
more
about getting a ride he's just yeah
then his brother's [ __ ] dog because
if casey had a fish named albert and it
had died i would have been like all
right casey do in loving memory of
albert let's go get some sashimi and
celebrate
his honor his death wouldn't it be
better to have like a steak
yeah to be fair i didn't really think
about that siblings do wild [ __ ] to each
other they do
right i don't have any so i don't know
oh so it's like rooted in their
childhood do you think there's something
like shared example like um somebody
that you might call like a brother or a
sister
in life yeah not blood bond yeah
sometimes you treat them
way better because there's no backing
yeah you know what i mean that's true or
or like the siblings
uh when you're like actual blood
siblings too the threshold for like
like of course you're gonna forgive me
we're blood you know what i'm saying
that threshold can be like way
farther for some people to do ridiculous
[ __ ] that is thicker than what like just
like just like that conversation like
other family members be like oh it's
your family though you should give them
it has nothing to do with the
i never believe that or whatever right
it's just you're gonna say that anyway
because it's like it's your family don't
you think that's the stupidest rule on
earth
yeah that family should get special
treatment no good people that treat me
good should get special treatment that's
what i'm saying that's true
um but like yeah let's say it wasn't an
animal like even that
are you the [ __ ] am i the [ __ ]
where the girlfriend sold the guy's car
like the guy
was really attached to the car it's like
if you're if someone you care about is
attached to something whatever it is no
matter how stupid you think it is
like getting rid of that thing that they
love so much is
really [ __ ] up yeah you laugh behind
closed doors talk [ __ ] not to their
faces
yes let them more side of the door first
you have to go on the inside kick him
out of the room first close
go to the park and laugh about it with
everybody else and then come back and go
i'm sorry you lost your goldfish
[Music]
you